hi everyone what's up I'm Alana or
Charan on and welcome to my Channel
today I'm going to be talking about the
fact that Target and Kmart in Australia
have pulled Grand Theft Auto 5 from
their shelves effectively meaning that
that game will no longer be sold in
those stores before I get to that I just
wanted to say sorry I haven't posted a
video in a while I have been super busy
and some of you may already know why so
in direct relation to that I just wanted
to say welcome to all of the new
subscribers and thank you all so much
for the supportive comments I I couldn't
appreciate it more thank you so much I
kind of feel like I have a whole world
on my side right now and that's amazing
and I didn't expect it so welcome and I
hope you enjoy my silliness here so a
petition on change.org got over 46,000
signatures asking that Target stop
selling Grand Theft Auto 5 the petition
does say a few things that I suspect
aren't particularly well researched such
as it's a game that encourages players
to murder women for entertainment I
don't think that it does that ever and
this mis mytic GTA 5 literally makes a
game of bashing killing and horrific
violence against women I don't think
that this game does either NE of those
things in their press release though
Target said Target Australia will stop
selling the R-rated video game Grand
Theft Auto 5 following feedback from
customers about the game's depiction of
violence against women the decision was
made following extensive community and
customer concern about the game we feel
the decision to stop selling GTA 5 is in
line with the majority view of our
customers so first things first I don't
think there's anything wrong with Target
or Kart choosing not to sell a video
game I believe that they are basing this
on U Mass consumer demand and I think
it's good on them that they are
listening to what a large portion of
their customers care about and there
have also been comments about Target
being hypocritical for also selling
violent movies and selling Nerf guns
which was specifically someone called
Mary from the guardian and I thought
that that was an excellent point so yes
I do think that Target being
hypocritical here but at the same time
they are just responding to a petition
so that in itself isn't that much of a
problem but there are other problems as
someone who has played a lot of Grand
Theft Auto 5 I would absolutely contest
that the game encourages violence
towards women or makes a game out of
bashing women I don't think it does that
very vast majority of people that you
kill in Grand Theft Auto even in really
brutal ways will be men I feel like
those who made the petition probably
haven't played much of the game and have
just seen the one thing that I do
understand people having an issue with
because the petition is said to be
written by sex workers who I assume
encounter quite a lot of violence I
understand their perspective I think
specifically the issue that they have is
that you can pay a prostitute to have
sex with you and then run her over or
beat her up or light her on fire to get
your money back I totally absolutely
understand why people are uncomfortable
with that content It also says in the
petition and uh this annoys the crap out
of me games like this are grooming yet
another generation of boys to tolerate
violence against women even though it's
an r18 game so boys shouldn't be playing
it this is the problem that I have with
this I'm fine with Target and Kar not
selling the game their choice totally
doesn't affect me don't think it affects
most Gamers I completely understand sex
workers specifically but a lot of women
in general being uncomfortable with the
fact that you can have sex with a woman
and then light her on fire afterwards
that's pretty messed up really but if
you have those problems because you
don't want boys to be influenced by them
you're you're making the wrong argument
here in my head it doesn't make sense to
stop an R8 game from being sold to
children by taking it off of shelves
when it should never be sold to children
at all because that goes against its
entire purpose and the rating The Last
of Us in Grand Theft Auto are two
fantastic games that have come out
recently that are specifically for
adults games are now being made for
adults as well as for children there are
two separate markets and we need to
realize that so Target have the right
not to sell it people don't have the
right to complain about it influencing
children because it's not meant to and
you shouldn't be buying it for them so
that's it for me today everyone thank
you guys for watching I owe you a Q&A
for hitting 40,000 and 50,000
subscribers but I'll do that when
traffic kind of slows down and I said
I'd do a room tour but I'm not sure if
I'll be able to get my room cleaned up
before I move because I'm actually
moving to a different continent pretty
soon so that's exciting but that's it
for me today everyone I'll see you next
time
byebye